en italie dans l'émission danse avec les
stars qui s'appelle ces deux ballando
con le québec qui est diffusée sur la
chaîne rai uno
ouais c'est voilà vous dites c'est une
très grosse chaîne
il ya une énorme polémique un membre du
jury amis note de zéro un couple
d'hommes qui dansaient ensemble car il
ne trouvait pas ça sexy c'est regarder
[Musique]
wen
attendez
l'autre voire totalement hors contexte
[Musique]
voilà alors ça fait une énorme polémique
mathieu parce que cette espèce de
connard qui est dans le jury que je
connais pas ça a été plus loin de ça il
a dit il a dit en plus vous mettez vous
faites un choix qui vous met en péril
pour le reste de l'émission de danser
avec un homme et je refuse de noter
c'est donc au début l'année zéro mais au
début de la séquence il dit je refuse
même de noter deux hommes qui dansent
ensemble
non c'est même pas de l'homophobie c'est
là ils acclament c'est hallucinant fouet
activement les témoin l'a pas été viré
mais ça et crée évidemment beaucoup de
polémiques pour des il ya eu un autre
jury très défendu qui a mis un disque à
équilibrer de la moyenne
l'amour vire fois que deux hommes
dansent ensemble c'est arrivé en 2016
d'une fois aux états unis mais en fait
les réactions sont tellement aux
virulentes que ça pose des questions à
la chaîne ça fait 3 millions de cette
somme et téléspectateurs et sur un an
ils soient et sans recul de 400 milles
pour bâtir et commerçants ce qu'on pense
pardon mais n'empêche qu'au france par
rapport aux nôtres quand même pas et
c'est la face à calais se pose la
question je pense qu on y allait d'un
cochon alors je dis que non moi j'en
suis sûr et je le dis que oui c'est vrai
je leçon aux deux hommes qui dansent
ensemble ils devraient en tout cas je
dis qu'ils le feront pas moi je vous
aime mais prend londres et paris abbas
que vous voulez va très bien on par y
aller très haut le coeur je pense qu'ils
sont pris les pieds dans le tapis est ce
que le jury ne peut pas faire son monde
d'avoir découvert la séquence y adhérer
pile sur avant les assiste aux
répétitions il servait très bien aller
dans son sens donc ils ont voulu faire
un coup de com comme ça voilà c'est ça
ça raté vu les conséquences pédiatrique